à entendre certaines interventions on a
l'impression qu'on est vraiment dans un
régime de pensée unique
on a l'impression qu'on ne peut pas dans
cette assemblée dans notre société
avoir un avis sur l'immigration qui soit
divergents de ce que pensent les soi
disant bien pensants
alors moi je vous le dis très clairement
je suis hostile à l'immigration et
hostile à l'immigration à la fois pour
des raisons concurrent jacques turrel et
pour des raisons structurelles
tout d'abord pour des raisons
conjoncturelles tout simplement
mais quand je vous disais qu'on est dans
la pensée unique on n'arrive même plus à
s'exprimer passé honteux bon pour des
raisons conjoncturelles tout d'abord
parce que au moment où nous n'avons du
chômage au moment nous avons des
difficultés économiques considérables
ce n'est certainement pas la peine ce
n'est certainement pas nécessaire de
charger la barque en créant des charges
supplémentaires et des difficultés
supplémentaires eh bien mes chers
collègues actuellement une femme
d'agriculteur une veuve d'agriculteurs
touche beaucoup moins que ce que touche
un immigré qui vient chez nous qui n'a
jamais travaillé pour la france
eh bien eh bien mes chers collègues ne
faut pas s'étonner avec des
irresponsables de la pensée unique
il faut pas s'étonner du résultat des
élections voilà alors je voulais vous
dire aussi que je suis hostile à
l'immigration pour des raisons
structurelles par le passé et mon
département en est un exemple
nous avons eu d'énormes vagues
d'immigration des polonais des italiens
et des portugais et c'était des gens qui
ne posait pas de problème
c'est des gens mais il faut le dire et
il faut le dire il faut avoir le courage
de le dire et on avait et ça a été
également le cas ça a été également le
cas des gens venus des gens venus
du sud est asiatique oui s'il vous plaît
laissez s'exprimer l'orateur et ça s'il
vous plaît la pensée unique s'excite le
ça a été le cas également des gens qui
venaient du sud est asiatique est très
souvent quand on avait des gens qui
venaient du sud est asiatique bas les
enfants c'était les premiers de la
classe bon actuellement avec des gens
qui viennent d'autres endroits
ce ne sont ni les premiers de la classe
mais oui mais oui mais oui mais oui et
c'est vrai monsieur le président mais
c'est pas normal
si vous voulez bien laisser parler
l'orateur allez-y monsieur besson
mais voilà alors aujourd'hui par le
passé l'immigration conduisait à
l'assimilation aujourd'hui l'immigration
conduit au communautarisme et on a
actuellement des quartiers on ne va plus
et ce sont les mêmes gens là mêmes gens
qui sont dans ces quartiers et j'estime
qu'il n'est pas pensable qu'on ait
aujourd'hui des piscines où on sépare
les hommes et les femmes
il n'est pas pensable que l'on fasse des
menus communautariste dans les cantines
scolaires et je voudrais terminer
mesdames et messieurs je voudrais
terminer on nous a dit tout à l'heure on
nous a dit non monsieur le président
je souhaite m'exprimer les 30 secondes
de plus à les y voilà
alors monsieur le président en 30
secondes de plus face aux tenants de la
pensée unique est bien ce que je
voudrais vous dire tout à l'heure on
nous a dit que l'immigration avait
conduit à des gens qui étaient de très
bons français des français remarquable
et c'est vrai necker madame curie et
cetera c'était des français remarquable
simplement
j'aurais voulu que la liste soit
continuer et mohamed merah coulibaly
s'est aussi laisse son lecteur pour
conclure me temps l'immigration
d'aujourd'hui c'est les terroristes de
demain